ukraine's footballers are about to play
a match that could define their
generation
beat wales here in cardiff and a place
at the world cup is theirs
as the war with russia goes on at home
it's a chance to take their role as a
rallying point for ukrainian pride
all the way to qatar
this is sport we don't expect any favors
from our opponents just because of our
situation but for us this is the most
important game of our lives and will do
everything possible to win
stars like alexander zinchenko who plays
for english champions manchester city
epitomize the footballing excellence of
the team
their importance off the pitch was shown
by the impact of the 3-1 win in scotland
that got them to this knockout final in
cardiff
the welsh will be wary but this
passionate footballing country is also
sensing a moment in history
ukraine could hardly have a more
motivated opponent for this match wales
haven't reached the world cup since 1958
to put that into some context the player
who knocked them out of that tournament
was a 17 year old brazilian called pele
wales have their own version of pele in
gareth bale
the five-time champions league winner
has just left real madrid
and has shown before that with him wales
can beat anyone
we're all
massively motivated to qualify for the
world cup we put ourselves in with a
great chance one game to go
we know it's going to be a difficult
game against a difficult team
and we have that most respect for them
but yeah it's all on the line come
tomorrow and
we'll give everything like like i've
said the welsh have chosen the more
intense atmosphere of the 33 000
capacity cardiff city stadium
instead of the double capacity
principality stadium across town
but ukraine will have plenty of support
of their own both in cardiff and around
the world
not least those watching back home
paul reese aljazeera cardiff